thrombosis is the formation or presence
of a blood clot within the circulatory
system blood clotting can be useful as
it prevents excessive blood loss when a
blood vessel is injured but clots can
also form when they aren't needed and
cause serious medical problems let's
look at three such problems in deep vein
thrombosis a clot forms in the calf or
thigh as a result of stasis or slow
blood flow for example in people who
experience long periods of inactivity or
in response to inflammatory mediators
from surgery trauma or infections the
clot can cause pain and swelling if
parts of the clot breaks off into the
blood stream it can end up lodging in
the lungs this is called a pulmonary
embolism and can be life-threatening in
individuals with atherosclerosis a blood
clot can form within an artery supplying
blood to the heart muscle in association
with an atherosclerosis plaque the
obstruction to blood flow can result in
a myocardial infarction or a heart
attack
in patients with atrial fibrillation the
most common form of cardiac arrhythmia a
clot can form as a result of the
ineffectual contraction of the left
atrium if the blood clot leaves the
heart and travels through the
circulatory system to the brain a stroke
can occur during blood clotting the
blood cells are held together within a
mesh of fibrin fibrin is the end product
of the blood coagulation cascade and
medicines that target individual
components of this cascade have been
developed to inhibit blood clotting in
high-risk patients warfarin is one such
medicine it's an oral anticoagulant drug
that's been used for around 60 years
warfarin prevents clotting by lowering
the levels of active vitamin K a
molecule essential for the maturation of
a number of the blood coagulation
factors it's commonly prescribed to
patients with deep vein thrombosis or
pulmonary embolism and to patients with
atrial fibrillation but unfortunately
many commonly used medicines and foods
modify the effects of warfarin
additionally how patients metabolize
warfarin varies considerably and so its
activity has to be monitored by regular
blood testing because of these issues
many patients who should be taking
warfarin do not do so and investigators
have been searching for other more
straightforward therapeutic options
several non vitamin K oral
anticoagulants or no acts have been
developed over the past 15 years or so
the bigger Tran is a direct thrombin
inhibitor that has been approved for
patients with deep vein thrombosis and
pulmonary embolism and some patients
with atrial fibrillation three-factor
10a inhibitors have also been approved
for use in these settings in Europe one
of these drugs rivaroxaban can also be
used in patients who've had a heart
attack
in contrast to warfarin the effects of
the no acts are unlikely to be modified
by food and other medicines and they can
be given in a fixed dose without the
need for monitoring importantly though
sometimes the effects of anticoagulant
medications need to be reversed very
quickly for example when a patient's is
experiencing uncontrolled bleeding or
during an emergency surgery to reverse
the effects of warfarin patients can be
given vitamin K but until very recently
specific reversal agents for the no acts
have been unavailable I dare you system
AB is a specific reversal agent for
dabigatran that has now been approved by
the FDA for clinical use
it's a humanized antibody fragment that
binds dabigatran and prevents it from
interacting with thrombin a reversal
agent for the factor 10a inhibitors is
also currently being reviewed by the FDA
this agent and Dex Annette alpha is a
protein derived from human factor 10a
and X Annette alpha acts as a decoy by
directly binding the factor 10a
inhibitors and preventing them from
interacting with endogenous factor 10a
other reversal agents for the no acts
are in earlier stages of development
specific antidotes for no acts could
help to manage their risks more
effectively enhancing their usefulness
in the treatment of thrombotic disorders